はじめ）こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーと
たなっち）こんにちは　たなっちです
はじめ）はーいえーたなっちさん
たなっち）はい
はじめ）あなたつい最近まで学生さんでしたよね？
はじめ）どうでしたか？学生生活は
たなっち）…いやーまぁ楽しかった
はじめ）勉強してなかったですよねー？
たなっち）勉強はしなかったですはい
はじめ)このＦランだいがくがぁぁぁぁぁ！
たなっち）あははｗグサってきすぎる
はじめ）はははｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）僕もたなっちのことをどうこう言えるわけではりません
はじめ）学生というものを離れて2年以上が経っております
ポンコツ野郎でございます
はじめ）まあ2年以上ねバカな動画を作ることに専念していると
はじめ）流石に僕も脳内の芯からアホになってしまっている
はじめ）そして彼もまた…
はじめ）生まれたてからの…芯からのｗバカｗｗ
たなっち）はははｗｗ
たなっち）言いすぎでしょ　親泣きますわ
はじめ）ｗｗｗ
はじめ）いや、賢いんですよ　賢いんですけど
はじめ）やっぱ勉強という概念においては
たなっち）う〜ん
はじめ）たなっちと俺がちょっと比較的かなりバカなんじゃないかと
はじめ）多分皆さんが想像している以上に我々はバカ
はじめ）ですが我々もなめられちゃいかんと
はじめ）なめられてばっかりじゃダメだということで
はじめ）今回こちらに2018年度の
はじめ）えー東大のえーっとｗ前期の入学問題を4科目準備しました
はじめ）今年の春にあった東大の前期の入学試験問題の
たなっち）うん
はじめ）えーと国語、数学、理科、社会を持ってきました
はじめ）英語は調べたんですけど非公開にされてたみたいで
たなっち）へー
はじめ）とりあえず手に入ったのが国語、数学、理科、社会の4つでございます
はじめ）東大ってことは多分これがまぁ日本で1番難しい
はじめ）入学試験問題だと思うんですよ　普通に考えて
たなっち）うん
はじめ）バカ2人が力を合わせればまぁ東大の入試問題だろうが
はじめ）俺たち2人がよってかかれば
たなっち）うん
はじめ）東大がどれだけこうダメージが与えれるかっていう
たなっち）ああー
はじめ）そういうちょっと限界に今回挑んでみたいと思っております
たなっち）たまに勉強したくなりますもんね
はじめ）たまに勉強したくなります
はじめ）最近は特に僕は漸化式への意欲が強くて
はじめ）数列を意識しながら漸化式を作ることを主に考えております
はじめ）漸化式わかりますか？
たなっち）全然わかんないｗなんすかそれ？
はじめ）あはははｗｗｗ
はじめ）はいというわけで只今なんと時刻がえー朝のもうすぐ5時
はじめ）徹夜状態でフラフラなんですけども
はじめ）フラフラのバカ2人合わせても東大にどれだけはむかえるかってのを
はじめ）今回実験的にやってみようと思います
たなっち）あぁ〜
はじめ）ちょっと気持ち厚いかもしれませんがまぁ気にせずにいきましょう
はじめ）まずは国語です　これやべーぞ
はじめ）ってかあれだ　いやうわぁ　うわあれだよ
はじめ）たなっちこれあれだ
たなっち）はい
はじめ)これやばいやつだ
はじめ）俺は気づいた
たなっち）ん？
はじめ）センター試験はマーク試験なんだけど
はじめ）2次試験だから書かせるのが多い
たなっち）まじかよー当たんねーっすよそれ
はじめ）いやーちょｗｗｗ
はじめ）まぁニュアンスが当てればまぁ点数になるって考えて
たなっち）確かに
はじめ）ではまずは国語から行きます　では
はじめ）量子力学を基盤とする現代の物理学理論にほかなりません。とはとういうことか説明せよ
たなっち）ちょおっｗ意味わかんなくないすかこれｗｗ
はじめ）はははははｗｗｗｗｗ
たなっち）ｗこれ笑うだろう普通
はじめ）いや大丈夫でもよく考えろ
はじめ）まず俺たちがやんなきゃいけないのは
はじめ）それにおいてまぁ量子力学を基盤とする現代の物理学理論にほかになりませんとはどういうことかを説明すればいいんだよね
たなっち）まぁここの棒線部の部分ですよね
はじめ）うんそうだね
はじめ）これはどういうことか説明するのね
たなっち）うん
はじめ）読もうぜ　その、まずこのそのを何かを明らかにするのが大事なんだよね
はじめ）そのは多分ミクロな粒子の運動のマクロな痕跡のことなんだよね
たなっち）うん
はじめ・たなっち）運動のマクロの痕跡がその
たなっち）痕跡ですね
はじめ）う〜ん
はじめ）荷電粒子が通過してできた水滴や泡、すなわち
はじめ）ミクロな粒子の運動のマクロな痕跡が
はじめ）その粒子の存在を示す証拠であることを保証しているのは
はじめ）量子力学を基盤とする現代の物理学理論にほかなりません
たなっち）とはどういうことなのって
たなっち）ふふｗ
はじめ）はははははｗｗｗ
たなっち）やでもこれ多分1解けないと、2解けないっすよね
はじめ）いやでもよく見るんだ
はじめ）(５)漢字を書くだけでいいんだよ
たなっち）あっほんとだ
はじめ）そうだつまり俺たちはまず(５)で
はじめ）無理な質問は無理にとこ、とこ、解こうとしなくていいんですよ
たなっち）うーん
はじめ）時間がかかっちゃうんで
はじめ）論文の問題って基本的に漢字を答えさせる問題があるんで
はじめ）フタ
はじめ）フタ？
たなっち）うわああああああ
たなっち）え？　　　ｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）あ、やべー普通にズルしようと思った
はじめ）素粒子のような理論的な存在の実在性を疑う人はおりません
はじめ）しかしその実在を確かめるためにはサイ…クロトロンを始めとする
はじめ）待ってやばいサイクロトロンだって
たなっち）ふぅーん
はじめ）やばいよ　言葉がわかんない
はじめ）フランス革命と明治維新って具体的に何があったかって言われると
はじめ）色んなことがあって
たなっち）うんうんうんうん
はじめ）それを含まれた事象なんだよ多分　抽象的な概念
はじめ）あのーすげー心空になちゃっててそのまままぁ成長しちゃって
たなっち）うん
はじめ）ゴミ人間になってしまいました
たなっち）これは多分なかなか返事がこなくてって事だと思いますね
はじめ）そういうことですね
はじめ）うちも置かれずー　　おおおー
たなっち）これを見て　　　この人が
はじめ）なるほどね
はじめ）でも古代の王のことを話してるんだよ
はじめ）古代の帝王は
たなっち）あっ
はじめ）それで後悔したのよーみたいな
たなっち）あーそうそうそうですね
はじめ）国語終了です　お疲れっしぃー
たなっち）おぅっしーーー
たなっち）すごい　国語40分で終わらせてるじゃないですか
はじめ）あっタイム的には悪くないっすねー
たなっち）そうですね
はじめ）続いて数学いきます
たなっち）開始
はじめ）はい
はじめ）えーっと座標平面上に放物線Cをｙ= あっ
はじめ）x＝2………
たなっち）え、すげーそんな感じだった記憶はありますけど
はじめ）あってるよ多分
たなっち）あってるあってる
はじめ）解ける問題を解くのがポイントですから東大は
はじめ）いやーなんか懐かしいな実数解って言葉もわかるんだけど
たなっち）うん
はじめ）単調に増加するためのaについての条件
はじめ）単調に増加するっていうこの単語の意味がわかんないんだよ
たなっち）フンッｗｗ
はじめ）数学終わり
たなっち）はーい
はじめ）いやーちょっと理系ーなんですけど
はじめ）悔しいことに何一つわかりませんでした
たなっち）すごいでも11分で終わりました
はじめ）あっタイムはまぁまぁまぁ
たなっち）タイムはいいですね
はじめ）3時間目社会です
たなっち）はいー
たなっち）開始
はじめ）俺日本史がなんにもわかんない人間なんだよね
たなっち）ああーだって俺だってさっき俺が言ってたの聞きました？
はじめ）ううん
たなっち）だって俺前世平安時代つったんすよ
たなっち）俺の時代　俺の前世より前の話ですからねこれ
はじめ）なんとおき平安京だもんね
たなっち）うん
はじめ）あー　ちょっと若干この人の方が早いのか
たなっち）いやーなんか幕府的な話だったっけかな
たなっち）でもまぁそういうなんか借金的なのも全部帳消しにするよってやった末で
はじめ）それを貿易的　交易的なことをしにきてるんだけども
はじめ）それをなんか密輸してやってるから
はじめ）終了　終了　社会しゅうりょーう
たなっち）終了？
はじめ）社会やってみて思ったのは
はじめ）なんか参考資料はたくさんあるんですけど
はじめ）根本的ななんか知識がないと解けない問題だらけで
たなっち）うん
はじめ）なんか色々考えてみ、みたはもののちょっとよくわかんなかったっすねー
たなっち）持ってかれましたね体力
はじめ）持ってかれた
はじめ）無駄に疲れた　でも全力は出したと思うんで
はじめ）最後理科でーす
たなっち）はーい
はじめ）よーい　どん
はじめ）ｖ＝v0＋atなんすよ
たなっち）なにそれ
はじめ）これ速さっていうのは初速度と時間によって増加していく分の合体がvにあたる
はじめ）ようするに、普通の速度にそのあと時間足して増えてくやつを足したのがそのもののスピードじゃん
はじめ）科学終了
たなっち）生物　任せてください
たなっち）終わりました
はじめ）おつかれーっす
はじめ）英語の除く全科目終了いたしましたー
はじめ）じゃー僕はちょっとこのまま採点してくるので
たなっち）はい
はじめ）しばしお待ちください
はじめ）えーーー全科目120点満点
たなっち）ほう　はい
はじめ）でございます
たなっち）はい
はじめ）で採点は結構甘めにして
はじめ）基本的に1問6点くらいらしくて
はじめ）で三角でみたいなやつだったら3点
たなっち）うん
はじめ）2つ答えるやつで片方あってれば3点みたいな感じで
たなっち）ああ
はじめ）ちょっと緩めな計算でやってみました
たなっち）はい　そうですねはい
はじめ）えー東京大学…
はじめ）2018年度
たなっち）はい
はじめ）前期試験
はじめ）国語
たなっち）はい
たなっち）すごーい
はじめ）すごい
ファ↓ファ↑ミドラ↓ファミド
ララーラシシドーラ
ドシラシー
シドドレーシ
レドシドーファーミレ
シラシミーソファ―
ファミドラ
ファファファファ★
はじめ）480点中47点でございました
たなっち）おおおおお
たなっち）でもまぁｗ
たなっち）いや俺すごいと思いますよ
たなっち）だって10倍したら470点ですからね
はじめ）まぁそうだね
はじめん天才！